what's too much in the talking  situationship courting whatever whatever  you want to call it in 2022 face  it forcing everything too quickly  especially if you don't really like or  you're just trying to figure things out  it's like when you're dating someone in  the beginning you always say I don't  know what I'm looking for I'm not  looking for anything because if it  doesn't amount to anything it didn't  amount to anything but amounts if if you  say oh yeah I'm looking for something  I'm looking for something and it doesn't  matter I think some somehow you're a  [ __ ] now so you know uh so that's  kind of just guys not wanting to be the  bad guy and it's getting open yeah yeah  because then she can't come to you later  until you promise something that you  didn't